is that a curtain or is that your green
screen
oh this is the green screen yeah it's
the power of uh
it looks really believably like a like a
you know printed shower curtain
i suppose it does because it already has
you're seeing the shadows you've got the
ripple kind of thing and i and the very
it actually doesn't have any ripples on
it it is perfectly flat i think it's
that it um no the shadow the light
yeah
you're right thank you and also lower
right something's something's obscuring
it or something in the lower right oh
that's the edge of the green screen
yeah okay yeah this also makes it look
like it's just naturally anyone's
throwing me yeah no i put a [ __ ] i'm i'm
actually recording from the bathroom
today i put a shower curtain behind me
uh what are you eating amazing you come
on this podcast when you eat
raw fresh cashews i respect all the most
depressing kind of cashews
yeah but no no salt on those do you put
some cashews i don't want flavor i like
a honey glazed cashew that's nice that's
a nice i'm trying to cut the sugar and
honey right down so
these kinds of things are filling and
not uh it's just it's just protein
basically i love nuts dude
quotable i know as soon
should have rethought that one um no
mike i wanted to ask i love carrots
i do also love carrots
let me talk to you about a raw carrot
have i told you guys about my thing with
carrots
mike loves peaches
eggplant is what you're going to say
yeah yeah you beat me to it i was gonna
i should have said i love eggplants and
mike loves peaches
don't like peaches uh mike i was gonna
gonna ask if you've seen dune or have
you still have you still not done that
i've not i'm still reading the book uh
you guys are more than welcome to chat
about it a bit i'm fascinated with what
you're both thinking about it sure i
mean we kind of got that off our chat we
did already touch we did already touch
on it
i wanted to invite more
uh opinions because like people have
started tweeting about the what they
think the the best picture is gonna be
um because i guess we're almost halfway
through november will be when this is
published so it's like everybody's
thinking about like what the game of the
year is what the best picture will be
and i will say
my current game of the year
came out of nowhere um did i talk to you
guys about inscriptions this inscription
it's everyone's losing their mind over
that game
oh good and i did someone came up to me
in a pub the other day and said my
someone i wasn't talking to this person
mike you've got to play inscription and
walked off it's fun the funny thing is
they thought you were a difference they
thought
oh [ __ ] sorry i thought you were someone
else it's really good um i got a code
from clara who works with devolver who's
wonderful and i was like cool i'm dive
down to play a spooky looking game it's
halloween let's do it and then i played
about an hour and was terrible but like
it presents itself as a very pixelated
looking
card game certainly a lot of similar
mechanics to magic the gathering which
i've played for forever um but that's
not a good hook for a lot of people is
like oh it's a card game i don't care
about it yeah but it's
not as i've experienced
it uh it's a card game that
not only is it like haunting and weird
and creepy and some of the cards speak
to you and have characters
it's also an escape room so sometimes
you i'm not gonna say too much more than
this because the reveals of this game
are like what make it [ __ ] awesome
it's like how far is it it's a priority
to play it's so good um
you can get up and walk away from the
cards
and there is other stuff around you but
you do have to play oh that's cool
in the woods or whatever against this
creepy person who's demanding to play
cards with you you do have to do that
but you're also in a physical location
and you're trying to get out um
it did strike me as somebody
saying you know
in the world of magic or hearthstone or
the the popularity of quick to pick up
short interval
um
uh card video games
what else can be done with that and the
idea of sort of
putting it in its own like narrative
diegetic space i mean in a way that's
kind of what you did mike um sounds like
they've just done the horror version
horror the escape room part of it i
didn't even know there was actually an
early version solitaire conspiracy that
had that kind of concept in it that they
were like
like it was that you were irritated i
i've not played the game so i don't know
where they go with it but like yeah that
you were oh you should solitaire
conspiracy is fun it's pretty good
greg miller it's all right
other actors
um
what's what's hilarious someone said to
me the other day you have to keep making
dlc and just have every other actor
except troy in it and the great irony is
like the one other dlc i would consider
doing i already know is troy yeah yeah
so we'll see might do it but yeah
can't do it it would be ruined it would
ruin the museum
um but yeah no there was an early
version i'll do it on his behalf
i'll wear i'll wear a troy hat and
everything very good that'd be awesome
i'd play that
but yeah sorry yeah there was a an old
version of it where it was going to be
uh where you were because you're the
premise is you've been kind of put in
this room to to do stuff
um and the original version was going to
be that that was going to be a literal
room you were in i think that's all
video games isn't it you're put in a
room to do stuff
i feel like that might be pretty broad
you know what i mean you know what i
mean you're kind of locked in this room
and it's uh it was it's look it's really
late here um
but uh it was uh it was yeah it was
honestly in the end we just realized the
fmv stuff was more fun so we just kind
of focus in on that a little bit more
but yeah
yeah it wasn't a super interesting
anecdote to be honest like not one of my
best
well yeah the decision making behind
different choices there is interesting
and i i think we were going to do a
thing and then we didn't and then we did
game design
uh the yeah the
the creativity of inscription is what
got me again a game that i played that i
didn't know anything about that
currently is my front run of the game of
the year
benefited by units plus according to
steam spy in the first couple weeks
what's that good
steam spy which i know
is you know approximately it's often not
right steam spy it's but it's it's in
the ballpark uh based on other
developers i've talked to because their
data set is super limited compared to
the old days but they
they have it marked as um
uh half million or more
sales that makes sense from the review
count review counts often a really good
metric for how well game sold what is
the number again like it was like
multiply the number of reviews times 48
or something right it's something like
it's in it's in that ballpark of like
somewhere it depends on the
oh yeah so totally if ever you're like
here we go give away all the secrets on
the podcast like if you're ever
interested in how well specifically an
indie game has done i don't know if this
tracks to triple a
but yeah if you usually the number of
units a game has sold will be
around 50 times the review count
is a
good rule of thumb some some some games
genres are different it's not again like
steam spy it's not perfect it's it's
honestly a similar sum to what steamspy
is doing to be honest under the also
some games
plus there's sometimes like a cultural
sort of like everybody like review
bombing or things like that will throw
off those numbers
yeah the easiest way to find out how a
game sold is to befriend the person who
made it and ask them that's the best way
um
i don't know
i mean devolver had a pretty good week
oh my god haven't they
yeah yeah i was going to ask you guys
your thought on this um
uh
ipo and i i was blown away at their at a
nearly billion dollar evaluation that is
now actually closer to two bill right it
was like 1.5 billion yeah that that was
my my biggest takeaway was i think it's
awesome i love devolver i'm a huge fan
of so many of the games that they
release i'm very glad they exist
stock market um or them being publicly
traded always scares me a little bit
because it's like does that mean they're
going to change are they going to have
to change are we going to have more
micro transactions in devolver games uh
but
stoked that they're considered to be
that valuable like that's that's awesome
like i'm i'm waiting on what i would
have guessed me too i wouldn't have
guessed anything close to that much so
it's awesome they make good stuff they
deserve it it's that's that rules
i wonder what annapurna would be or is
that opponent already publicly traded
because the film division
annapurna i think is private isn't it um
yeah it's like owned by megan it's a
rich kid right yeah yeah it's a rich kid
that's one
i think just owns it outright
yeah i could be completely wrong i saw
that um
nathan gary who was at sony and was uh
hired by megan to create annapurna
interactive
um has been upgraded to their like
essentially narrative content vice
president across both film and games now
that's interesting so he came in via
games via sony
um
and is now
kind of helping steer the ship i think i
think my gut tells me annapurna was kind
of like
the non-they were essentially a
counterpart to the weinstein company but
without all the horror show that is
harvey weinstein but they basically were
the boutique indie who were making the
kinds of movies that were
you know
the high end of low budget you know like
like a jordan peel type movie where it's
on the metric of
from zero to marvel or zero to star wars
they're
low budget 10 15 million but that's a
lot better than a micro indie or
whatever or even 20 or 30 million
um but and they're very they're
boutiquey there are movies that the
cynical version is their movies that are
designed to win oscars and they do
and certainly in the weinstein company's
case they really they really obviously
between
the quality of films that they would
make and also just the
you know the nature of the strong arming
that apparently he would be doing
to to kind of coerce academy voters
uh they certainly had a good track
record but i would say it's one of those
it's a shame that
that that name is so marred from the
standpoint that the legacy of a lot of
their films are pretty amazing actually
and they made a lot of movies that big
studios wouldn't make and that's sort of
what annapurna their goal was and it's
obviously the same general temperament
of annapurna interactive i mean
the game was what remains of edith finch
and then it was flower
they did flower
like they ported it you mean i mean
flower was that game companies you know
just from from ps3 days for some reason
i thought that they like had brought
flower to ios they did and yeah
and that was an opponent that did that
it's because annapurna
nathan and deb both are ex-sony and have
a lot of great relationships so and and
same thing edith finch was was supposed
to be first party sony
um
it was the second game of ian dallas
after the unfinished swan which was a
sony exclusive and they canceled the
project and annapurna rescued it
happens a lot more than people realize
they did out of wilds donut county they
did florence they did
pathless pathless pathless as i would
call it uh and they did sam barlow's
game which i really liked um didn't get
as much telling lines as her story but
yeah i liked that they did cyanide
sayonara wild hearts he did kentucky
root zero
it's like hearts was beautiful i love
that game it's so much fun it's all of
the games they make do exist in in
a box
the box is things that other publishers
wouldn't fund like but they're all
incredible like very very good catalogue
of games there that are all really
different than just a lot of other
companies just wouldn't go for like
and it's the same so the same i think
it's the same again i don't know
with any certainty but it strikes me as
the same mo as their film mentality
let's make films that other people don't
yeah have the sort of
courage to make or the interest to make
or the
you know the marketing savvy to make or
whatever the case may be whatever their
real rationale
they they want to make those kinds of
off the beaten path but my impression is
that the game division is actually doing
better than the film division like they
have more winners
per
capita as it were on the game side which
is that's that would be my guess i have
not i know nathan but i have not spoken
about this i'm definitely not betraying
any confidences here this is purely my
speculation that that
he's essentially
like hey you're doing things really
right what
what can what can we learn over on the
film side as well because they've
they've made a lot of interesting films
but i think very few that you could call
commercially successful yeah but they
have one oscars
probably i think so
um or at least
yeah they make they make great stuff and
i'd be interested to see like how they
would do on a similar scale as devolver
which is again still awesome but i think
developers considerably more
commercially successful they've also
been around a lot
for sure but my my two games of the year
right now are both devolver which is
death's door and inscription those are
my top two i think death loop is
probably in third for me but like that's
i don't know i i didn't know what i
expected this year like did either of
you have any front runners for a
game of the year as arbitrary as it is
the perception is that it's been a quiet
year partly because i guess reception
i've seen people i i well i i i it is
until you list it like it it was a quiet
yeah it's always there but then when you
go well this came out this year resident
evil ratchet like i also think that we
have no concept of time anymore i think
it's also
i think i think what it is is um
there's also no
there's no like one ring to rule them
all this year the way like last year we
had the last of us
uh sushima and goes to sushima and and
doom materials
in the will of the wisp all of those
that came out last year holy [ __ ] it did
it was before the pandemic that was my
last event that i went to
their launch party oh yeah
yeah i mean it's it's obviously it's
it's almost two years ago oh my god
it still feels like that was four years
ago because of the pandemic that was the
the last one that i went to and i mean
before the fans came in because they had
like press and then and then fans and i
was like because of covert i think i'm
going to leave early yeah it's like when
we saw each other at dice that feels
like i mean dice was the last one 50
million years ago
yeah wow us us and shu
as as god intended this podcast it's so
good
but yeah i think i think this year there
hasn't been
the like the defeat like the one game
that has just cast a vastly outsized
shadow relative to the other like the
last of us two and goes to tsushima both
last year really like
took up a lot of the oxygen in the room
and rightfully so that's not meant as a
disparagement this year i feel like even
even eternal might be the one for me
well that's the thing is i love
fraternal but the thing is even the
games that are really really really good
like returnal and death loop
are games that are such specific
genres and also similar genres um that
it automatically ostracizes a lot of
people um i actually i see what you're
saying it's not like a big proud pleaser
no not enough people are going to play
them because they're not an action
adventure ultimately uh and i feel like
like maternal a lot of people found too
hard i weirdly and i'm not a person who
brags about
finding video games easy did not
actually have much trouble with
returning i didn't know i mean come on
you play
that's true but like there are games
that i'm bad at and your calibration is
way off for shooters i think yeah i
don't know if i feel like it's a shooter
but in any case
i didn't
have trouble with with return
no i know what you mean it i think it's
got a much smoother and i'm sure fans
have opinions all good and bad on this i
think it has a much smoother on-ramp
than
most souls likes like it just has that
kind of or or almost whatever yeah i was
[ __ ] terrible at hades when i started
it eases you in in a way that i think
makes it really accessible in kind of uh
it doesn't scare you off basically it
lets you get to the start of the good
stuff before it kind of starts kicking
your ass which i think is good and i
think we're all
like generally there are just some games
that you're going to be better at than
others i i can't play a platform and
save my life
like but i did what was your take on um
what was your i remember we talked
briefly about psychonauts and just the
length of cut scenes incredible i think
psychonauts 2 is fantastic like
that game
i remember when i was playing through it
i kept having these moments where i was
like
oh man if i was a kid i would have been
so happy like if i were a kid i'd be so
happy to play this and then i was like
what
no this is making me feel like a kid and
i'm happy to play it right now like
psychonauts 2 i think is incredible it's
so creative it's so fun like actually
smiling playing it funny personality
um i do think the the pacing with the
cutscenes
it was a downside i think there's like
some controller remapping issues that
they might have gotten rid of like the
fact that you couldn't just auto have
levitate without going through some
settings kind of silly but i really like
psychonauts too but that's also a game
that not everyone's going to buy into
like last year's like ghost of tsushima
or last of us because it looks a certain
way like people are off put by it
aesthetically so it's like there's just
no game that you're right there is no
one game to rule them all this year
i'm surprised guardians of the galaxy
hasn't
or doesn't seem like it's dominated the
conversation from like a mainstream
perspective because that game is so much
better than it i expected to be i
thought it looked really bad
and then i played it
and i was like oh holy [ __ ] this is
actually really good i said do you think
that's what it is like
marketing poorly and i also think that
maybe coming off of avengers which i
thought was terrible
um probably people expected the same
thing
that's a shame because i i think yeah
that game surprised me me too
and it because it almost
it's definitely not got the kind of the
the budget and time of like a a
first-party sony game but it felt
weirdly like a sony first party game it
had that kind of it felt like uh i don't
think it's lacking in budget
particularly though right i mean it's
not a compared to the last of us it's
going to be like
yeah it wasn't marketed like them
yeah it's funny how our expectations how
reactionary we can be because
i enjoyed avengers more than i thought i
would because i heard it thrashed about
by people so much oh you think yeah and
then i enjoyed guardians less than i
expected to because it got so much more
praise than i was expecting
although i haven't finished guardians
i've only played maybe
two hours so i know you should keep
going it gets better yeah it opens up
yeah avengers breaks my pc avengers is
like oh wow in a year where everybody
was talking about cyberpunk being buggy
i kept being like
avengers
was so broken for me like i would go to
a level and the boss would spawn in a
room that was inaccessible by accident
um people would fall through the floor
like instant it came out or something
yeah but i was also on pc and i think it
wasn't optimized for pc where cyberpunk
was the opposite so it just it was not
functional and i would i would try to
shut the game down um but couldn't and
then any time that i tried to do
anything else or like tried to boot up
another game it would be like game is
already running you can't and i would
have to shut my pc down like hard shut
it down any time that i tried to play
that game like it was terrible
um then i yeah i played it straight away
i think it's a little bit better now and
again was also better on console which
isn't that i remember enjoying the
campaign of it i thought the campaign
was
was decent like i think if you played it
single player it was all right
yeah that's how i played it yeah yeah
the um do you think do you think i mean
maybe that's the elephant in the room
maybe
maybe cyberpunk would have been
that barnstormer had it not had the kind
of launch it did maybe that's the maybe
that's the the and that's the thing
that's left the empty space where the
kind of game you're talking about would
be because if cyberpunk could come along
it should have been kind of an
indisputable champion
yeah it
and it should have i'm sure that a lot
of people on the team want to know look
i still had a great time with that game
playing on my beautiful 3080 with my
ultrawide monitor i've really enjoyed
cyberpunk um but that's been the
sentiment yeah
i think the narrative suggests like
whenever i've said that i end up like on
twitter or whatever i end up with one
person being like you're saying that
because they made you and i'm like no no
no and then 100 being like no me too i
actually really like this game
um i i really did it unrelated that they
made you you're it's coincidence that
also happened yeah my chair
no i really enjoyed it because
they sat on the floor otherwise
yeah i would have gotten rid of the
chair tonight i i like that i was
playing through that game and i was like
holy [ __ ] this is cool to like a lot of
moments in it that i really enjoyed
really love the character oh i want to
get to it i want to get to i want i want
that that
next gen port and i'll play that i'm
glad they're taking more time now
for sure but like hitman three also came
out this year it went through god that
was incredible loved it yeah that might
actually that might be the winner for me
so it sounds like that came out this
year
it sounds like
um
the
issue is not a shortage of
good and
not just good but sort of well-liked
or even beloved games but that they they
come and go from our
perception
you know like return was one that i
remember got a lot of
it had a whole flurry of activity and
then as soon as it was in the rear view
mirror
like three days it was so weird i
expected that conversation to last a lot
longer
maybe
i mean i think that's related to like
the
international mood for the last year
maybe yes maybe that's a part of it yes
for sure we are conversations are moving
faster and faster and faster but i still
maintain that i think that we've had a
lot of specialized games
like like not everyone is going to want
to play return on no matter what
um guardians in theory more people
probably would but the marketing heard
it um hitman it's always been
a lot of people played it but it's been
it's always been niche for a triple a
little nightmare came out this year also
very good but also limited um yakuza
like a dragon i guess that technically
came out before then
um it was definitely been the case came
out didn't that so i don't know how um i
don't know about audience retention and
things like that i don't know those
numbers but just from my perception of
my twitter feed
it was it's the same as with the aliens
fire team where the first few weeks
it was
a [ __ ] ton of people playing it liking
it talking about it
and then it was like oh now
this thing's out
move on to the next thing you know and
um at least
multiplayer scares me because if you're
not in the conversation you're you're in
trouble with a game like that yeah you
need to be current
yeah it's an interesting it's an
interesting
it's my my gut i still haven't played
death loop i'm sorry ironically i have
you guys to blame because
you said
the first time you play set aside like
four or five hours and i just simply
haven't had that much continuous time to
play
a game i'll play you seem pretty fine
one hour when you go on your
international
travels too busy to play deathly better
spend ten hours on a plane
that's the thing i know what you mean
i still play plenty of games but that's
a long that's a half day yeah
to be honest that's why i bounced off
death loop like i played i lost you you
only have to do with that one time and
then you're good
but i but i still feel that sense it's a
hard game to put down though when i was
playing through that game
like guardians of the galaxy i'm not
quite finished i'm about three cause the
way through and i'll probably go and
play it for half an hour after this
because it is that kind of easy pick up
and play popcorn easy game yeah it's not
that's how i really think
that's how call of duty is for me every
every whenever a new call of duty comes
out it's always like exactly what my
diet is looking for in that moment they
seem to have
my internal clock of
some some good
reasonably low rent shooty fun
like they released them at the at the
date at the same rate at which i the new
vanguard is out now yeah yeah and i've
started playing it and it's exactly that
i'll play for 30 minutes basically get
through a mission set it down be fine
for
you know a day or two yeah and then i'll
be like oh you know i don't have i have
a call in in 45 minutes i don't quite
have enough time to get anything
substantive done so i'm just going to
keep chipping away at that i do that
with those
yeah and forza horizon 5 obviously
people are losing their minds about i
have not played it yet i usually jump on
forza pretty fast but that just came out
and it's getting it's currently the
highest rated game of the year what's
the prize in five really yep really
um i've always loved those they are
they're really good and i guess it's
never been my genre
well
my thing with forza as someone who
has always liked racing games um and has
always liked cars in general i've always
said that i think forza horizon is the
racing game for people who don't like
car games
that's true i've experienced that
playing it's a fun arcade sandbox guy
but yeah yeah
they're fun um and
there's a lot of stuff that they do to
make it so that you don't really need to
care about
racing games in general the genre in
general which is super impressive
um did either of you play it takes two
with your significant others
i didn't the aesthetics kind of put me
off a little bit
i don't love the look of that because
we've played we we played um brothers
and uh what's the prisoners
get
in one no get out get in
get
what you're talking about
my favorite joseph ferris game get in
what was it called
um
[ __ ] hell i'm gonna google it i don't
remember my way out
a way out a way out
that's right get in
get in
get it
that's perfect that's good right it was
good you like you love that game
it's also fantastic like there's a lot
of games that came out this year that
were fantastic for different reasons
it's really creative and
what impressed me the most and i i'd
really love to hear your take on it mike
if you
get over the aesthetics which i get
um i will they have so many many games
there are so many the entire game is a
series of mini games stitched together
co-op mini games too
meaning do they have to make
different mechanics every single time
like it's incredible you're like holy
[ __ ] how did they
in this kind of similar way that
avengers
the amount of dialogue i'm like how the
[ __ ] did they do that
like there's so much of it that i
actually found it annoying um but i'm
also very important galaxy oh yes sorry
sorry sorry not avengers guardians of
the galaxy yeah there's so
much super chatty they never shut up
which some people like but like just in
a way that like a way out
is so consistently creative in terms of
literal game design in terms of
mechanics you mean it takes two [ __ ]
hell yes i mean it takes two
i'm very awesome i'm sorry
[Laughter]
shut up steven get out of get out in
front of that one yeah
well that problem is that's viable so
yeah well i guess the takeaway of all
this is that uh the game of the year is
mass effect legendary edition i think
it's jurassic world evolution too which
i i think it's mlb the show 21. so
okay mine's inscription and i think
inscription probably stands a pretty
good chance
of of getting some awards um it will get
some it'll get some nominations for sure
at least yeah also forgotten city
i said so that's the one that's the
that's again another time loop game but
that's uh it's like rome is it or greece
ancient rome uh yes ancient rome i
believe
it was originally a skyrim mod
repurposed and now published this year
as a stand-alone game um i think it's on
gameplay really good things yeah like as
well so it is a really interesting year
though but i feel like usually after
a new generation console launch there is
a little bit of weirdness
like the last year of the previous
generation
we got the last of us two the one before
that was the last of us like
you know you get you get your absolute
bangers in that final year that come out
and are amazing and then the next year
is like
a little bit strange and i think it's
largely because of delays which
obviously have also happened um because
i've covered disproportionately right
now
but it does feel like a weird year
the console shortages will also be
playing a role that's definitely making
publishers more cautious because
if you know if you
if you don't know if the audience is
actually able to play your your shiny
new game then there's a lot of incentive
to sit on it for a year and make it make
it a bit better and sell to a larger
audience next year a good point
you know one that i thought
based on the initial trailer one that i
thought would surely
have a shot and i i i've played a couple
hours of it and it's
it's very charming and um
and very inc
like shockingly pretty was the uh kinah
bridge of spirits
great great game yeah i really enjoyed
that too yeah it really it's one of the
first games that i've played that
genuinely
feels like a playable pixar film uh
just like they nail the aesthetics so
well which is not surprising given that
it's
not really made by traditional game
developers it's like an animation studio
making cheers austin
um it's true
what does that mean
we're just thought it just no i was
taking the face the way the way you say
that obviously it's good it's not made
by game developers almost like oh well
traditional game develops um but there
is some interesting stuff in there
i've had
skills
with them the other day that like we
couldn't do that i'm still hoping to do
at some point where i really wanted to
ask them about how they prioritize
certain things because there are some
things in that game that are very
clearly animation studio uh when you're
playing it it's very noticeable like um
your jumps the animations aren't
interruptable so if you do a double jump
say you're jumping to get on a ledge and
you double jump to get on the ledge
instead of um
reaching the ledge and grabbing it you
will go the whole way up and then grab
it when you fall down so after the jump
animation is completed you're falling
down which is clearly because an
animation studio is like we have
complete animations you finish the
animation the animation looks nice and
it does that in terms of player feedback
it means you've got like a millisecond
of a delay before you grab the ledge and
you're like did i oh i did grab it but
it reminds me odd world that kind of
totally like odd look where it feels
different
in a way that almost no games do um that
it almost feels slowed in some places
because of that but it's like but they
so distinctly stuck to that vision of
making sure everything looks
really good and it does and also like
how much of it did you play austin
um a handful of hours i don't know how
long it is i didn't get the impression
that i was at the beginning of the game
anymore
i'd get i don't actually i would say i
was
yeah i would say i made it between a
third and a half way through then
because boss fights
they get tough
yeah and and they introduce like they
they they dole out mechanics in ways i
didn't expect
like it i i kept thinking oh they've
probably played their hand now and then
they kind of throw me something new to
play around with and i thought
pretty good like but it's just so it's
one of those rare ones where
i actually found
i've kind of evolved into someone who
who has a bit of a hard time with um cut
scenes now yeah um and like that was
again it's like i have this lifelong
massive
massive love of all things tim schaefer
and it really was hard for me to get
past i couldn't finish psychonauts and
i've got friends telling me oh this is
my game of the year and like i'm a
lifelong fanatic for point-and-click
adventures i had the exact same problem
not that it's a point-and-click but you
know what i mean um
his vibe and i just thought
you know even the new call of duty has a
few cut scenes that ran a tad longer
than i was expecting or i was feeling
myself like
come on let's go
uh but um but
keena they're so beautiful
that i genuinely was like
take your time yeah you watch a little
pixar short absolutely they really it
yeah what amazing debut as well right
totally amazing
is the name of the studio yeah
yeah very good um road 96 also really
cool indie game um austin we were
recently on the awards jury for indicate
was there any any games there that you
wanted to give a shout out to
blind drive is dope
that was going to be what i said yeah
there were a couple others that i really
wanted to love uh because they had a
really it's always the problem
especially with indicate where they're
you know they're trying to shine a light
on the kind of
you know the on font replay types you
know the ones that are the that are the
um
the disruptors that are doing something
genuinely unique and interesting and
they'll they'll give an award to a game
that's pretty unpolished just because
they try they genuinely took a stab at
something really unique and there's a
few of those that i really loved for
that
um
and but
ultimately it didn't add up well
enough some total like whether the lack
of polish or just the lack of substance
to back up their cool little thing that
they thought of or whatever didn't
really flesh it out as a
as a full-on kind of i just kind of
unapologetically love this game yeah i
agree um but i have admiration my
favorite of which i'm blanking on the
name but there was one where you're
playing as
it's kind of a side scroller
where your you're you're you're playing
as a shadow and you're also controlling
the light source yeah um
it was like a puzzle
like sort of 2d platformer-ish sometimes
that game was really cool what's it
called it was the idea where you're
yeah
help redeem me because it was one of
those where the the
the mechanic of controlling the light
source which stretches the shadows and
creates in and therefore you know they
have this dynamic lighting system but
your character is themselves also a
shadow so you're controlling two
characters at once in a sort of
co-op single-player type way although i
do think you can play it two-player i
played it single-player i also played it
single-player
that was but that i remember thinking
that's such a clever idea like that's
something given infinite time i would
never have thought of that if i put on a
game designer hat and fully embrace all
the imposter syndrome that will then
immediately flood in if i try to do that
um i thought given infinite time i
wouldn't think of that specific mechanic
you know what if i what if the character
is a shadow therefore they can stand on
a ledge that's like an outcropping of a
shadow um you know like if if my phone
is sitting on the edge of a table like
this and therefore it's casting a shadow
that they could stand on you know if i
move the light way over there suddenly
that becomes a road not even a ledge and
i can cross the whole map that way and
it was like
it's damn clever that's a great idea is
it larger than light yes it is yeah
larger larger than light um
it it was really cool it's it but i i
kind of felt the same way that i was
like not 100 though this isn't like uh
oh my god but it was still like really
[ __ ] cool conceptually larger than
light i want to see yeah and it's played
by it's the kind of thing that yeah that
i'm glad you're looking at because i was
just about to say that's the kind of
thing where somebody who can think of a
of a novel clever bit like that you
think i wanna
i wanna know what they're up to after
this yeah i'm sure it's a really small
team it's um 20 what games
yeah that's the name of the studio yeah
it was neat that was definitely one of
the ones that i liked the most there was
some in there that i like i didn't like
at all a lot of people doing like very
different stuff
um it's it's such a fun thing about
getting to be on those juries is playing
indie games that i otherwise wouldn't
try but blind drive is more than i would
recommend yeah never even out of half of
them
yeah um
blind drive is made by lo-fi people
and
um it's an audio-based
black comedy is what it advertises
itself as and it's really [ __ ] cool
like it was my favorite of the bunch by
a significant margin i mean these games
aren't going to be included in the award
shows and it's like there's a good time
for us to talk about it because usually
the jury cut up for the game awards is
if it's not this week it'd be next week
so nothing that comes out beyond this
point can be included um after the next
couple of weeks i don't remember exactly
what date it is but like we pretty much
everything is out that will be nominated
this year for most of them for most of
the websites um blind drive i don't
think will be but it's really cool and i
think it's like
very cheap i would imagine yeah it's ten
dollars that looks really good it's
super cool
definitely recommend trying it out if
you have some some spare time to do it
because you can also like come to grips
with it pretty quickly
um
you know another one that i realized
we're we're not mentioning
is um
one of the most profoundly unique games
of the year um that i'm blanking on the
name of but the game that's controlled
through your camera um
what
don't worry carry on was it also one of
the indicate ones no no this is a game
that's uh because
that needed a camera yeah i don't know
what you're talking about really um it's
um
ah crap it's gonna drive me crazy
like on your phone
no it no it's a pc game and it and and
when you blink it it it monitors through
facial recognition your blink and it
will cut the camera every time you blink
no no no no
is it a horror game
no um
oh it is i remember this it's like it's
like and you go jumping forward through
a life or something like yes
i have heard it's driving me crazy um
this is terrible i gotta figure out the
name of this thing um i'm trying to like
i'm actually amazed this hasn't come
across your radar before your eyes uh
before your eyes yeah god your google
skills are faster than mine i wrote when
you blink the camera moves game i didn't
i did indie game blink and they opened
and it got there the first suggestion is
a
pewdiepie youtube video from april 16th
we figured it out before your eyes no i
haven't even heard of this oh wow it's
got really high review scores too yeah
no this is one that's made
much more of a splash um and obviously
you know it's a very um okay based on
the way it looks i i feel like i'm
getting like edith finch vibes i think
that's a fairer comparison it is it is
more like a drama in movie terms it's
closer to a drama than a
certainly a horror
i wouldn't call it horror at all but
that game to me again it's just one of
those where somebody had a really clever
idea and he would think
i'm not sure why it's not like i'm
fascinated to know how
a game like that that's that novel and
well received can escape the notice of a
lot including people like you who really
have your ear to the ground like it
makes me fascinated because no failing
on your part and i wouldn't even call it
a failing on their part if they've
gotten out there and obviously there is
just a sheer amount of content and noise
but like i think we're just all siloed
in our little worlds now i think if
you're not
yeah
i miss a game like that but i would say
it's that it doesn't compel people to
talk about it something about it is like
cool that's the only reason i've heard
about it that's the thing i've only
because it was like i kept hearing
people go have you played this did it
come out while i was in nicaragua
because i
knew what was going on
it did not it did not
it's um excuse
there's a bunch of
stuff that's like come to different
platforms on this list but
yeah it's just um so death story is also
really good i really really enjoyed it
um but those would be like that's my
list sofa i'm i'm so curious to see how
this
ends up like what is there anything
that's coming out never mind the awards
because you're right like we're pretty
much at that cut off in terms of like
the baftas and dice and blah blah blah
but but is there anything that's coming
out before the end of the year halo
infinite
that's that's uh that's that's that's
your biggest world evolution too yeah
what is it with you in that game i
remember you you mentioning this book
first one was genuinely like the most
fun i've had it's kind of kind of just a
game i just melted into basically for a
week what what i don't i know nothing
about this game what it is it's like a
super tycoon it's a zoo tycoon a very
very very at least the first one i've
not played the second one yeah the first
one very accessible zoo tycoon
whereas it where if you're if you were a
jurassic park kid as well like the idea
of like very much so i'm gonna put the
t-rex paddock over there and i'm gonna
make it so that the raptors are there
but i'm gonna put like some stegosaurs
between them and the general public so
that there's less chance because of
course the dinosaurs keep breaking out
because of course they do it's jurassic
park game um but yeah no it's really it
was really funny there was a dlc as well
the nuisance of that like ah the [ __ ]
raptors killed 20 more
you know yeah you have to build we have
to shut down for a week
and you get like your mo your pr
department like calling you up and
complaining to you that like this is
terrible for business we people are
losing faith in the whole jurassic park
idea it's genuinely like it's it's it's
clever it's but it's made by um frontier
as well so it's brilliant goldblum
recently streamed it
really yeah is that a thing a friend of
mine
um no i think it was probably sponsored
he did it with jesse cox um let me see
if they did the first one on the second
one
well he did i remember he did a really
he did he did the interview circuit for
the first one and just did
absolutely jeff goldblum ridiculous
interviews with a bunch of like games
press people which is a lot of fun did
he voice for the game yeah
oh yeah he's he does the voice for well
and then there was a jurassic park dlc
that i had a few of the other actors in
i wish to god voices like alan grant
that would be the most ultimate jeff
goldblum type move i feel like is to go
in and voice a different character
gamespot had him
i i don't mean to offend anybody by not
knowing my simpsons
but gamespot had him as part of this
like they finally got jeff goldblum on
the video game to her
um yeah
they had him do lines from like this
simpson scene where
something is burning in an oven
oh it's the
ham the the this principles
yes yeah whatever it is quite famous i
believe that's not oh it's not a jeff
goldblum scene though no they had him
voice it for fun and then had
i love uh jeff goldblum had a guest spot
in an episode a long time ago as actor
troy mcclure's agent uh and uh he's so
good uh he's so where they they're
making the planet of the apes musical
uh and he goes we would like for you or
he goes the studio wants you to play
the human
and he goes it's the part i was born to
play and i always thought that was such
a [ __ ] what's that there's the the
song there's the samadaya sarah what's
the name of the name
doctors as doctors yes yeah oh my
goodness it's a genius i remember it
well oh my goodness
but yeah no that's genuinely the first
one was a lot of fun so i'm looking
forward to playing the new one um yeah
yeah i love it it's not going to be
anyone's game of the year but like i
will just built into it for a weekend i
i will love it i will i have the i have
such a soft spot for
those one in a million
licensed titles like that that are
actually quite good you know where
because it's just there's still such a
dark cloud over that concept that
there's a lot of challenges there's a
lot of challenges to licensed work you
know so like the walking dead was the
first one i remember when that game was
literally contender for game of the year
it was like wow people have finally
started to realize
there there doesn't have to be a kind of
baked in curse or like a cynical
the studio is just licensing out their
ip just hoping to bring in some extra
cash but like they really actually want
someone to make something good with it
and that was because the suits
owned games consoles as kids that's the
transition that happened if you look
generationally and we experience this
like all the time throughout john wick
and
i've definitely experienced it in
conversations since like the the suits
of the film industry were gamers yeah as
kids sure they understood it they played
goldeneye that was the only licensed
game they liked like i literally
remember with john wick golden i was
brought up in like every other meeting
of like we gotta make one of those good
license games like golden eye okay
it's like when you're in that room
you're like oh okay that's that's really
cool that's a that's a good thing so i
think yeah i think the the ratio's
improving i think on licensed games
because i think as well that's a really
interesting observation as to why
uh
i think it's that i think it's also
i think it's also we're in an era where
the ip where people realize the the the
benefit of having like a cross-platform
ip right so everyone's everyone's
looking at like the you know the marvel
cinematic universe and going we need
something that can be in games and
movies and books and you know so i think
everyone's kind of people don't we used
to be the lunch box now we're an
extension of the universe video games i
mean like it's it's kind of uh there's a
bit more interesting awareness of the
role that it can be it's true there used
to be like a bad movie tie-in and now
it's its own property
not those still exist
largely on mobile um
there's a lot of that kind of stuff but
at the same time like i think i think
when you know when a studio like marvel
makes something like guardians of the
galaxy
they are intentionally using that as a
space where they can tell a different
story they can road test characters
maybe that they're thinking of bringing
into the movies they're they're looking
to expand and extend on that franchise
and kind of play with what they can do
it's uh it's a good test bed it's not
just let's get some cash which is what i
think it was when we were kids
um look at video games go who'da thought
hey look at them go relevant cultural
objects
even if they only stay in our
consciousness for one week at a time but
i think movies are doing the same right
now and it's like you know i'm i'm
looking at this list of what the um so
true the guest for oscar hopefuls are i
haven't heard a half of these movies and
i think that that that's it
you're right that that's not a
phenomenon that is pretty normal
but i think that it's worse this year
because of the lack of people going to
cinemas
means that there are less average joes
talking about movies
no one's casually seeing a movie in a
cinema every even if you're completely
okay and feel completely comfortable
going out in public you're still second
guessing that decision for five minutes
yeah and that for you know for casual
film audiences
yeah i mean i don't i don't i've been to
several movies i didn't second guess it
but there are constant reminders
that this is a narrow experience you're
seeing less movies yeah exactly you've
seen less movies
yeah it is fascinating like you're
you're absolutely right though that the
movie it's the same phenomenon because i
remember i saw the marvel um shang chi
and i quite liked it i was like this is
way better than i was expecting it to be
it's pretty awesome disney plus next
week i think yeah well worth watching it
it's it's tr i i really it's it's among
my favorites of the kind of standalone
or character introducing ones like it's
really really good
um had a lot to love about it really
gorgeous art direction and there's a
bunch of cool stuff in the third act
that i won't spoil that i was like that
damn
really into that and yet it's funny that
when i think back i think maybe your
time dilation is sort of the phenomena
because i think when did i even see that
wasn't that like years ago and it was i
don't know a month 10 weeks ago yeah
whenever it was in theater but i also
haven't seen eternals
it's just different
it's a different
vibe right now that i'll wonder how that
will adapt but yeah the conversation for
everything is is
moving really quickly like i can't
believe
that i didn't
i waited three four weeks to see james
bond and he didn't have any of it
spoiled for me
i still haven't seen it and i still
spoiled by my neighbor
yeah you said that last week that's nuts
that sucks so bad
i mean there's stuff that happens in it
that like
there are multiple things that could be
spoiled but
nothing it just it's
very strange to approach award shows in
general this year
even music i feel like is just passing
by and i i don't know if
yeah is that is
is that everything or is that just
twitter like what where is this coming
from
i think we're just all like blinking
stepping into the sun
again yeah maybe like it's that could be
that rebirth that cultural rebirth how
does that lead into conversations moving
quickly
well i mean
to bring up my theory of uh of of aging
and the passage of time
we've all
we so my whole thing was that the time
passes slower the more new new
interactions and new pieces of data
right
so it follows if you've been in the same
house looking at the same four walls for
a year
your the time flow would be moving
faster in your brain but also you're
going through stress which is like a
complimentary kind of slowing down
we're all a bit jumbled up we've all
we've all got kind of
jet lag like profound jokes also just i
wonder if
everyone is a little bit more online
because that's what they had to do to
socialize for a long period of time
and thus the
nature of engagement drives people to
move on to the hot thing a lot faster
because everybody is kind of consuming
content at a increased rate we're
spending more hours i don't know if
that's happening but i would say a lot
of people are spending more time on
social media than they were before thus
social media may be faster how could
they not be from the standpoint that
it's it is the primary way to interact
with people right even still relative to
two years ago yeah yeah
something just as an aside but since you
mentioned eternals it just made me laugh
because it harkens to your
days in the um
uh you know writing of reviews and being
part of that ecosystem of writers i saw
a headline that was going viral a few
hours ago
uh that twitter was trying to show me of
um it was like eternals has lowest
grade of any marvel movie yet and so i
clicked on the article and it goes
these
half dozen are given in a plus these
half or dozen or whatever are given in a
and eternals is a b plus and i and i was
like failing that's your scandal that's
your that's your uh
such a
i was like
it's amazing how consistent marvel
movies have been right just like they're
following these franchises
no they they if it was easy everyone
would do it right that's true that's
that i have a lot of risk my respect for
them has only gone up i watched i
finally
in the old days whenever a big
blockbuster movie would come out that i
wasn't particularly passionate about
that was always my wait till i'm on a
plane movie like that's how i've seen
pretty much every transformers movie and
because they're not really
my
like dune is the kind of movie i go out
of my way to see in the theater yeah uh
you know like
and i love the theater experience and to
me even like an intimate drama
about like people dealing with life is
better in a theater than at home like i
pro to me theater is de facto always
superior because i'm just you know i
live in la i moved here because of the
the magic of movies like i just love the
theater experience
but there's some movies that are just
less of a priority and and
black widow had slipped onto that list
for me because everyone was like it's
fine and then so i did finally when i
went to belgium a few weeks ago i
finally watched it on the plane and you
know i was in a nice seat with my proper
kind of
noise headphones and stuff and and um
i have to say i was like i think people
were unfair to this movie it's quite
good also like
like all the [ __ ] mcu movies i was
like i gotta say i really enjoyed this
suicide squad either
that was awesome
that one i feel like i have seen more
positivity than black widow did people
again i feel like i didn't see a lot of
negativity about black widow i just
didn't see many people talk about it i
think it was apathy it was this movie
would have been really you know because
it takes place right kind of concurrent
with civil war
and and there's no real reason why it
couldn't have just been made back then
because it doesn't really inform future
mcu stuff it just kind of was one of
those that it felt like well it gives
the origin story of her waist
yeah like
it's it's it's one of those things that
that um
they thought you know you know this is a
little
uh
you know maybe too little too late uh
kind of thing but it that i think that's
an unfair
the the mcu i think is better for it
being there personally but it's not it
doesn't it doesn't you know change
things the way it is also that's
actually the audience thing right like
it was uh it was uh you know it was uh
it was on disney plus but it was like
yes
and like they didn't really know what
they were doing with that one i think
maybe
then you're a great person to ask with
the way that they did it did you have to
you had to buy the movies individually
for all of them
subscription like
know that in the uk i think they're all
20 quid
which to be fair so cinema is much more
expensive in the uk than america so if
i'm going to the cinema with my
girlfriend by the time i paid for
transport and the train ticket uh sorry
trench transport on the cinema ticket
i've spent 20 quid on the trip to cinema
before i buy like concessions or
whatever oh yeah same thing it's like
for me so for us it was like a trade-off
of like yeah it's funny quick if it's a
movie we want to watch and
yeah
and i had to see jungle cruise as
quickly as possible because i'm a
massive theme park nerd and i had to see
the rock do all the jokes and he does
all the jokes he does all the jokes
i think it's 30
on disney like i remember paying that
for cruella maybe dollars yeah i'm 30
yeah which would be you know 30 dollars
yeah i enjoyed corella a whole lot i
thought that'd be really yeah like not
in terms of of
narrative
visually and the soundtrack i thought
were dope it was an enjoyable thing to
perceive
yeah and that's an interesting yeah no
no doubt about it that
that uh like the fashion stuff was
beautiful like it was so cool
yeah there's nothing here all the marvel
tv shows on disney plus were pretty
solid like there was a lot of that
stuff did quite well yeah i really
enjoyed being i liked vision um i
haven't watched what if i did recently
just watch some of star wars visions i
thought the first the first episode is
cool as hell
and then the second episode i was like
this is the worst thing i've ever seen
so i like it's a really weird mix but
because uh it's it's like love death
robots yeah where exactly it's a similar
thing it's it's different animation
styles uh disconnected stories so
some of it's really good and some of
it's
terrible but the problem is the terrible
stuff
one episode i was like i can't believe
you've done this to star wars like it's
precious like they haven't done a
million things to star wars it was like
oh awful like there's this like pop punk
band that plays it's just i just thought
it was so stupid um but the some of the
ones that honestly are just very
childish which you should expect from
the franchise that lucas said it looks
like it's like on the matrix right
they've done kind of uh
i was obsessed with matrix as a team the
animation styles are all they're all
different
um i don't know why i saw animatrix but
i certainly did
sorry yeah sorry
no it's right i was like 10 but i think
i didn't see it until later than that
i um
isn't it funny how star wars is uniquely
able to kind of re-prime us for
heartbreak unlike so many other
franchises like you're like how have you
done this to star wars we've said that
that's been the time position since 1999
that's and that's why it's my own fault
actually 1997. yeah they've done so many
stupid things with star wars across the
years but i'm still like oh my god this
ah but then i still love other parts
it's ridiculous it's stupid we all just
need to get over it
it's so it's so baffling i almost got
broken
like fully finally reached a point where
i'm like you know what i'm just okay
if they can do whatever the [ __ ] they
want i'm i'm an adult finally
you know you've grown up when you stop
being upset when star wars is bad but
here's the thing i still regress because
i remember in solo when this when the
tollbooth worker gives him the name solo
i was like
i was like i was like all right i guess
i'm i guess i'm out i guess i guess i've
just
i've just reached it's like that south
park episode where the adults everybody
is just speaking [ __ ] noises and nothing
is good anymore i was like i guess i've
reached that stage with star wars now
but then it's like i watched mandalorian
and i was like oh my god i love it again
it's so amazing and then there's like
little bits in you know season two where
i'm like how did you do that then i just
immediately i think that's the thing
about being one of the biggest ips
ever to exist um is that some of star
wars is for you and some of it isn't and
that's okay
and i actually think it's kind of wild
yeah for sure they do they they they
keep reinventing in a way that most
franchises don't those franchises will
just give you the same thing over and
over where star wars they try for stuff
and yeah sometimes i mean that's not for
you that's the biggest complaint with
the sequel trilogy is the lack of trying
stuff uh and that's why the the big sort
of hardcore episode eight fans of ryan
johnson apologists that they're like
that's the whole premise of why that
movie is controversial because
there's like the people that say hey
this one actually did try to do
something different and and you all
hated it so [ __ ] you for complaining
about things being static because you
rejected the one movie it's one it's
weird that's one of those ones that i've
kind of 180 on i still don't
particularly like that movie because as
a storytelling experience i felt like it
was just broken but at the time i
thought this is so out of step with star
wars i was definitely one of those
people that my instincts were saying
this doesn't work for me that as time
has gone on i've digested and i've
watched many like three hour youtube
videos i've seen a lot of those about
that movie more than any other movie
i've watched three-hour youtube channel
and i have to say i've been pretty won
over where i've said you know i
think that i can really commit and i
think also then seeing knives out and
being like he really is a [ __ ] great
filmmaker you gotta go back you're gonna
watch brick you've gotta go back and
watch like the older ryan johnson yeah
he's got a good pr
knives out being so good for sure people
were like oh i think the thing with the
last jedi is
very similar i didn't hate it upon my
first watch and i never felt as
staunchly against it as a lot of other
people did um but i still don't like it
and it i mostly don't like it because
of the storytelling issues like you
mentioned is that what is set up in the
previous movie that i was super excited
about
he shits on
and he shits on it not to create a good
trilogy
but to just be like it's different not
what you expected oh i i don't want to
we don't need to relocate this and my
god do i not need the comments
[Laughter]
like i don't like he's not i don't think
so yes he's he's pulling away from some
of the stuff in the previous movie but
to me it's about he's trying to broaden
it he's trying to show you different
kinds of stories but he's also but with
no end
the snoke thing
the snoke origin is uninteresting for
future storytelling i think he was
genuinely trying to set up a bunch of
playing pieces that you could spin off
star wars in 100 directions which was
exciting as an audience member kind of
to go oh this could be
somewhere so so you don't need to be you
don't need to be a rich kid to have jedi
powers cool you don't need to be or
you'd be part of
stuff like that which is like genuinely
trying to like broaden the playing field
um or or the guy the the
cool guy who flies spaceships really
well maybe he's not like awesome maybe
that's maybe we're going to move away
from that archetype there's just so many
things in there that was like just felt
like it was broadening what a
star wars story could be i don't feel
like snoke did that though because you
gave me someone to be invested in my big
bad guy
of two i suppose
um and then you just cut it off with no
replacement and so an audience is just
like
but what and then they're like somehow
is that ryan johnson's well well brian
johnson didn't bring about palpatine
i don't think
yes because i think
again we could get where he did about
this that one i think is his mistake
because
there's no easy setup
okay let's not even say it's ryan
johnson's mistake i'm going to say it's
like a more high level
mistake of them not communicating enough
between films but that's like there's no
way to jump from there that you're like
that makes sense that can circle it back
around when it's like that's what you've
set up
i i think that was the writing ryan
johnson's primary goal was to
break the circle and
try and allow for stories that go in
different directions
that many ways
okay
i think this is where the problem is
what you're exactly what you're saying
that they there was a double edge
there was a double-edged uh it seems
that there was a double-edged mistake of
not they've openly said they made the
movies kind of one at a time and just
picked up where the pieces left there
was no
there was no coherent plan which you
know love him or hate him george lucas
made two trilogies that actually did
have
um
a through line enough to at least give
you a sense
yes
there'd be less brother sister makeouts
if you have a long-term plan and it's
true franchise good point it's what what
they uh they wouldn't have had uh
incestual kissing
no well even there's a plow but that's
that's that the details the details were
not so
not honestly you're talking about i'm
talking about high level high level
storytelling of like the broadest
possible plot points that was that was a
that was because that was all just you
know archetypal hero's journey stuff the
idea was okay i've got this all
kind of loosely sketched out and then
and then you know by the time you made
the prequels that was like even fan like
i knew going in
by the time you did the prequels i think
yeah he absolutely had like a map for
what he was trying to do in terms of
getting it back to where he was yeah for
sure so i think the lack of i think the
lack of a three movie plan and also the
fact that like so they apparently they
just said you know the directors
uh you know take it take and run it make
it your own because colin trevorrow was
originally gonna do episode nine and so
the plan was like three different
directors kind of
just picking up where the last one left
off it's almost like improvising off a
jazz solo like this guy finished i'm
gonna just in the moment respond and
that this is a woefully difficult thing
so i think i think i think he was
responding to what he was given which
hamstrings a lot of choices and on top
of that
i do agree with you
uh mike he was he was
sort of saying okay how can i how can i
reject as much of it as possible and try
to take it somewhere new which of course
then really doesn't work if the third
movie is like actually we don't like it
yeah we're going to reject your
rejections and so it's like
yeah i like how just any conversation
where you talk about uh you get a bunch
of nerds to give opinions on things it
just it always comes back to the last
jedi
it's just always got to come back to
like but
it's the god wins laws has to happen
can't not be discussed i have a i have a
post-recording anecdote on this subject
sure ooh
related
i feel like that should be it for this
episode
we got our star wars in we did
we mentioned greg miller
we've really covered all our bases let
me enjoy the show hi everybody welcome
to play with this and i'm a lot of
friends i'm a video game writer that's
mike biffle he's a video game director
and that's austin wintery he is a video
game composer troy is sadly not with us
as he has just returned to the us and
has to catch up on a bunch of stuff but
will hopefully be joining us next week i
will see you guys then
bye bye
okay